un background de canada beach
comment allez-vous moi je suis de retour
du canada s'était très bien j'ai passé
de merveilleux moments j'espère que
c'est le cas pour vous aussi mais
aujourd'hui on reprend le travail le
meilleur travail du monde si je peux
dire je suis très content ça fait deux
mois que j'attends quelque chose
j'attends depuis deux mois les résultats
d'un test adn
pourquoi squeeze fait-il un test adn
écoutez c'est une histoire très simple
issu d'un traumatisme créé quand j'étais
au collège au collège c'était tout
simplement hyper classe de dire ouais
j'ai un peu de racines espagnoles way
pour ampère et vivait au portugal dans
un jeune âge suis un peu portugais mois
face à ces gens je ne pouvait que
répondre moi je suis 100% bave tout
j'adore rast'art fout là il n'a pas
nourri chine et où est ta gueule je suis
chiante org et aujourd'hui après 21 ans
d'ignorance sur mes origines je vais
enfin savoir d'où je viens bref il ya
deux mois j'ai commander un kit adn ok
j'ai dû mettre un coton tige dans ma
bouche pour récolter de la salive et
l'envoyer à un laboratoire
ils ont reçu le 14 juin nous sommes le
10 août au moment où je tourne cette
vidéo l'attention longue mais les
résultats sont là ok je viens de mettre
tous mes identifiants
c'est parti bienvenue du karcher
bienvenue dans le monde de la généalogie
adn sur cette page vous pourrez voir les
résultats de votre test de généalogie au
jeu tout excité dv7 à l'interprétation
paris génère résultats lignée paternelle
et résultats liés maternelle j'ai les
résultats de ça et de ça mais j'ai pas
les résultats du m 250,3 et ça ne paie
pas que parce que c'est du tout jugement
très attendu pour le 4 octobre
du coup je peux voir les résultats de ma
lignée paternelle ce que j'ai pris deux
médias tester il teste au sida il arrive
à voir les deux lignées paternelle et
maternelle bon je pars à mon mandat
maternelle alors je viens du peuple
d'origine celte envoyer une carte et où
71% europe occidentale et centrale 17%
péninsule ibérique faut que j'appelle ma
grand mère elle n'arrête pas de me dire
mais cas nous sommes 100% français je ne
sais pas de nounou mes arrière grands
parents à moi déjà été français je ne
sais pas d'où l'on vient je pourrais lui
dire mamie on est un peu de sang
espagnol si on retourne au collège on
pourra se la péter va me up hutin 12%
europe du sud est
ouais donc je suis quand même à 70%
d'ici est par contre 17% péninsule
ibérique mais ben sahar ça c'est
surprenant c'est je suis dégoûté de pas
avoir la carte paternels et maternels
voir mes origines précisément j'aurais
appelé ma grand-mère j'aurais pu lui
dire parce que là je ne sais pas si
c'est plutôt la lignée de mon père qui
viennent la péninsule ibérique où c'est
plutôt la lignée de ma mère et pareil
pour l'europe du sud est mais je pense
que ma mère je pense que ma mère c'est
l'europe du sud srl très bon et ma mère
ça n'a aucun sens au caire en tentant de
passer à l'origine préhistorique
le conseil européen a connu de nombreux
épisodes de migration humaine dont
certaines sont étalés sur des milliers
d'années la recherche la plus récente
sur ces migrations ancien suggère que
trois groupes majeurs du main nue en
effet durable sur une population
actuelle d'origine européenne des
chasseurs cueilleurs des agriculteurs
précoce et des envahisseurs de l'âge de
bronze
ok alors je suis que je vais jetter quoi
47 % d'agriculteurs 42% de chasseurs
cueilleurs et 11% arnaud européenne je
ne comprends pas ces valeurs je sais pas
trop comment le prendre je sais pas si
je dois être content ou pas ou alors
n'en avoir rien à [ __ ] je sais pas je
ne sais pas ce dock mec je suis 100%
européen mais j'ai 17% 200
espagne-portugal voyage ou jeu quand
même appelé ma grand mère je veux dire
mamie j'ai fait un test adn on descend
des celtes voilà elle fera ce qu'elle
veut avec cette information moi je
trouve ça très amusant
[Musique]
comment vas-tu mamie ouais ça va ouais
je suis rentré lâchions en fait tu en
train de faire une vidéo et je
t'appelais parce que j'étais j'ai fait
un test adn et ben écoute j'ai pas
encore les résultats exacts mais je sais
que nous descendons des celtes
voilà on descend des celtes du côté
maternel donc de ton côté on descend des
celtes toi aussi tu sais pas quoi faire
de cette information par contre j'ai les
résultats de mon sens à moi ça comprend
et les origines maternelles et
paternelles donc je suis à 70 % issus
d'europe occidentale et centrale
sans surprise 17% de la péninsule
ibérique donc espagne portugal et 12% de
l'europe du sud est donc grèce italie
ouais mais du coup à ton avis est ce que
c'est vous qui venait de la péninsule
ibérique où est-ce que c'est papa c'est
ça la question
moi je pense que côté maternel c'est
péninsule ibérique parce que maman elle
est bronzée naturellement bah voilà tout
s'explique donc qui ça vient de maman
mon avis mais alors voila mais c'est sûr
ça vient de vous et papa il est blanc
comme un qu il vient de la serbie c'est
évident et ben écoute
le mystère est résolu mamie tu es
espagnol ben j'ai surtout payé très cher
mais ouais en tout cas moi je suis à 17
pour cent espagnole mamie tu m'aimes
toujours restée une blague mais c'est
écoute ma famille on se voit bientôt
pour l'anniversaire de florent ouais ça
marche
ouais ouais c'est ça ouais ben moi de
même disait ma vie je t'aime [ __ ] j'ai
appelé hier comment en seulement 24
heures à la retrouver autant de chose à
me dire bah les amis je crois que voilà
la vérité vraie elle est là on a vu un
gars à cette carte chute et blanc des
chutes pas pour avoir un détail d'où
vient mon père et devient ma mère
écouter on le saura apparemment en
octobre j'en fais une vidéo quand il y
aura la carte du monde disponible pour
l'animateur n'est signé maternelle
c'est amusant mais n'ajuste pas y sommes
aulas 100 espagnole mais qui est nommé
calories et là à la jet ski souriment
jambes des imitations on n'est pas loin
du racisme voisine eh ben les amis c'est
la fin de cette vidéo vous a plu [ __ ]
je suis trop content n'hésitez pas à
aller mais c'est le cas et je suis trop
content [ __ ] ça fait vraiment depuis
depuis dix ans que je me dis mais c'est
pas possible maman nos enseignes à milan
ils viennent forcément d'ailleurs tu te
tais tu écoutes en compte svt et lucas
et ben aujourd'hui bon ben j'ai la
réponse
enfin bref la morale de l'histoire c'est
que on vient tous de loin en réalité
c'est totalement impossible que
quelqu'un fasse ce test est qu'ils
soient à cent pour cent français ou
alors c'est ultra rare ça se trouve vous
détestez les anglais et vous avez du
sang anglais pour finir mon gentil peu
importe d'où vous venez
moi je m'en bats les couilles ce sont
vos actions qui comptent pas vos
origines elle la morale nul de lucas a
les amis je vous aime
merci d'avoir regardé ça m'a fait très
plaisir de faire ces minots chatel s'est
depuis longtemps et puis à bientôt dit
envoie en espagne est reparti en
espagnol avions
[Musique]
ça